welcome to 2022 everybody great to be
back and there is so much to talk about
it's an election year the election is
getting going it's not going to take
very long that i can assure you we have
some good news to kick the year off with
including specifically that radical
republican
congresswoman marjorie taylor green has
been banned
permanently from twitter we will get to
that a little bit later in the day but
we have to start with some words of
caution and we have now heard from three
military retired military generals
who are sounding the alarm and saying
in 2024
it's not just
a republican coup
that you have to worry about you have to
worry about a military coup
one of the reasons that trump's coup
attempt didn't work
was that he's very incompetent of course
and he did not have the military on his
side now there's no shortage of support
for trump in the military but he didn't
have the generals on his side and what
these three retired generals are
pointing to
is the possibility that that could be
different in 2024 it doesn't necessarily
have to be trump could be a different
republican and they are now saying
you got to be careful about this
very good npr article retired general
warns the u.s military could lead a coup
after the 2024 election
and it says as the anniversary
anniversary of the insurrection at the
capitol approaches
three retired generals are warning that
another insurrection could occur after
the 2024 presidential election and the
military could instigate it the generals
paul eaton antonio taguba and stephen
anderson made their case in a washington
post op-ed quote in short we are chilled
to our bones
at the thought of a coup succeeding next
time
um they
have these are highlights from a
conversation you can listen to and i
encourage you to do so
how could a coup play out in 2024
the real question is does everybody
understand who the duly elected
president is if that is not a clear-cut
understanding that can infect the rank
and file or at any level in the u.s
military
and we saw it when 124 retired generals
and admirals signed a letter contesting
the 2020 election we're concerned about
that we're interested in seeing
mitigating measures applied to make sure
the military is better prepared
this is a crucial point
we lucked out
in a sense
that trump and his cronies were too
incompetent
and poorly organized to pull it off
and in addition if it ever got to the
point of actually
getting the military involved
the
officer class
and the generals in the military weren't
going for it but there was this letter
signed by retired generals and
high-ranking military officials i said
we don't believe the results
what happens if you see that within the
power structures structures of the
military is it likely no i mean even
they say you know when they're asked how
how worried are you on a scale from one
to ten
i see it as low probability high impact
i hesitate to put a number on it but we
need to be prepared for it
in the military we do a lot of war
gaming to ferret out what might happen
you might have heard of the transition
integrity project that occurred about
six months before the last election we
had four scenarios and what we did not
play is a u.s military compromised
so we advocate that that particular
scenario be addressed in a future war
game held well in advance of 2024 and
that is a very good idea the military
has a ton of extremism in it
there are
self-study projects done
we've talked about some of them about
extremism and radicalization in the
military there's a whole bunch of it
right now it is not common
uh prevalent
among the top brass it could change and
imagine if it did we know that there are
these boogaloo and proud boy types in
uniform
talking openly about their involvement
in the january 6th riots
it appears as though they're going to be
punished let's hope that that happens
there were members of the military that
participated as individuals on january
6th
and we know that this is a sort of
feedback loop
um
when
i've gotten emails from members of the
military who say david sir
uh on base
there's one news channel that's ever on
tv and that channel is fox news
um and so when we you know over the last
two months i've been making a more
concerted effort to say
this isn't just haha look at these
morons in terms of the january 6 stuff
in terms of the it was stolen by joe
biden stuff
it's yes
cartoonishly unhinged and the world
looks at it and says how could these
idiots believe this stuff how
what what has failed education media
society and the answer is yes all of the
above
of course it all has failed
but that doesn't mean we can just laugh
it off and i've been taking it
significantly more seriously over the
last couple of months
and this uh these interviews from these
three retired generals
should make all of us say
we can't just write this off as kooks
who could never get further than they
got in 2020
they could get further
and one of the biggest
components that would make that a
plausible possibility
would be the military actually really
being on their side so we're gonna
continue talking about it worth
listening to the interview or at minimum
uh reading the article from npr we'll
link to it in the description for the
youtube clip
for this story
folks the right has a new meme i don't
know
if mass formation psychosis
is completely killing let's go brandon
but it is spreading rapidly on the virus
front we have omicron rapidly out
competing delta
on the memetic front right wing memes
we quickly have mass formation psychosis
overwhelming let's go brandon they can
probably co-exist
what am i talking about mass formation
psychosis let me set this up for you
there's this guy called robert malone
robert malone is someone who
has for a period of time now been
credited with and taken credit for
developing mrna vaccine technology now
this is a claim that has been fact
checked quite a bit
it's a bit of an exaggeration what the
right wingers want you to believe
is that robert malone
is the guy who created
mrna vaccination and now he's totally
against it and thinks it's terrible and
dangerous and wants to destroy the
monster he created and remember all this
different stuff okay
a more sober analysis and you can just
google
a number of different
very good stories about this
is that he was one of many people
over a long period of time
who did research that contributed
to the development of the technology
which of course eventually can get
applied to one thing or another and now
a couple of the current covet vaccines
are based
on the mrna okay you get the idea right
so so
that's part number one
the second part is
robert malone
has now been uh banned from twitter
for spreading
covet disinformation
and this is of course bringing out all
of the
that's fascism
and communism
and authoritarianism and it's violation
of free speech and all these different
so it's bringing out those people
it's also bringing out the people who
are of the mindset of the the truth
trademark the truth about covet vaccines
and covet itself
is being suppressed it's being covered
up etc etc
so robert malone got himself an
appearance on an emergency podcast with
joe rogan
and in it he
i don't know that he coined the term but
he kind of made a portmanteau of two
terms that exist and that term is mass
formation psychosis he is saying that
this
mob psychosis plagues
um
the side of science when it comes to
covet
and what is incredible i'm gonna that
this clip has gone giga-viral millions
upon millions of views
when you listen to what he's saying it
sounds like he's explaining what is
plaguing the american right wing the
covid deniers the vaccine conspiracists
the trumpers the stop the stealers but
he's not talking about that let's just
get right into the clip and then we're
going to talk about it listen really
closely from
basically european intellectual inquiry
into what the heck happened in germany
in the 20s and 30s you know very
intelligent highly educated population
and they went barking mad
and how did that happen
the answer is mass formation psychosis
when you have a society that has become
decoupled from each other and has free
floating anxiety in a sense that things
don't make sense
we can't understand it and then their
attention gets focused by a leader or
series of events guys
he's describing trumpism
what we have i mean it's
do
i almost feel like i i'm over it's
it's too on the nose like i i feel like
if i give any explanation i'm over
explaining it sounds like he's
describing the mass psychosis of
trumpism that i've been talking about
for years but he's not he's talking
about people who accept the vaccine
science on one small point just like
hypnosis
they
literally become hypnotized and can be
led anywhere
and yeah and 70 something million of
them ended up voting for trump one of
the aspects of that phenomena is the
people that they identify as their
leaders the ones typically that come in
and say you have this pain and i can
solve it for you i and i alone
guys he's quoting trump
he's
he's quoting trump here is here is trump
literally saying i alone can fix it i
alone can fix it i will restore
law and order to our country do you guys
remember that it he's quoting trump
verbatim but we're supposed to believe
it's the
you know i don't want to call it the
left because there's republicans that
accept science and in paris
i've never seen anything like this okay
can fix this problem for you okay then
they will lead they will follow that
person yeah it doesn't matter whether
they lie to him or whatever that's
exactly what happened with trump he lied
to them about all of it i mean it's
how does it
now they're they're all on this now all
the right wingers now yeah doc robert
malone explained what's going on with
these leftists this mass format
the data are irrelevant and furthermore
anybody who questions
that narrative right is to be
immediately attacked
this is central to mass formation
psychosis and this is what has happened
we had all those conditions if you
remember back before
2019 everybody was complaining the world
doesn't make sense blah blah blah
um and we're all isolated from each
other we're all in our little tools
we're not connected socially anymore
except through social media there's
something about these types of typically
it's it's guys
where they talk in a certain way
i mean
where they they do what they're accusing
that when he talks about hypnosis
what you when you listen to the way that
brett weinstein has spoken about
vaccines he goes
well the um
it's uh
spike protein is cytotoxic and i i'm
concerned listen they have a way of
talking
and ben shapiro has it too although it's
a different way very different way of
talking
where it almost doesn't matter what they
say now what the now they're all talking
about mass formation psychosis what is
that
um this is a combination the term mass
formation psychology is a pre-existing
term and it just means like crowd or mob
psychology and they're just saying he's
adding psychosis to it to say well it's
a form of psychosis it's a mass it's a
mob psychosis of sorts
um
what is incredible about this is that we
have to share this because this is the
best description i've ever heard of the
maga movement
except he's not applying it to that when
i listen to it i'm thinking
wow what a
what a perfect analysis of what has
plagued this country
with the maga movement for years now
but he's not talking about that like the
the unaware lack of awareness about the
irony is incredible now just because you
come up with a name for something
doesn't mean it accurately describes
anything and the truth is i've been
describing what's going on since kovid
in this way
for a long time you know back in january
of last year 2021 i did a segment called
the shared psychosis of trumpism i mean
i i literally described this except he's
he's describing it but not actually
talking about trumpism in may of last
year i did a segment called 54 percent
of republicans
think trump riots were led by violent
left-wing protesters where i described
this
as a group psychosis that that's
verbatim the word that i used so it's
not a new concept
and it couldn't be more of an instance
of projection but
this is their new meme
robert malone is their new hero
and the new meme is mass formation
psychosis and they lack the ability
or awareness to realize it applies to
them better than to anybody else they
might point the finger at send me your
thoughts you can find me on twitter
deepakman curious to hear from you
remember that even in 2022 the david
pakman show continues to be sponsored
primarily by viewers and listeners
through the david pakman show membership
program i invite you to sign up
uh at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code wow 22.
that's and you have to say it that way
wow 22 all one word all lower case and
you will get a discount that is uh
this type of thing they might outlaw
this if depending on who wins in
november they may outlaw this type of
discount sign up at joinpakman.com okay
am i ready to tell you how insane the
u.s coveted numbers are no why not well
we don't have the full numbers from the
last few days because of the new year's
holiday i can tell you that the numbers
have gone nuclear
or nuclear to quote certain people okay
you know former president bush
but we don't yet have the full numbers
but it's looking like real infections
real because a lot of people don't test
at all or you know all that stuff
we may be talking 1.5 to 1.8 million
covet infections a day in the u.s u.s
okay real number we will get to that the
question about this
insanely transmissible omicron variant
is
what will it do
and for how long
in terms of hospitalization and death
although
if it's this contagious
the total burden
on society is going to go up because
it's so contagious you're still going to
get hospitalizations you're still going
to get deaths
if it is dramatically less deadly
as a percentage of cases of infections
it could very quickly accelerate our
progress
to the end of the pandemic phase which
will just go to the endemic phase one
place we are looking at very closely is
south africa because south africa was we
don't say it was the place it came from
but it was one of the earliest
countries
to
be very open about the data of the
number of people infected etc
we now have news from south africa south
africa says it has passed its fourth
wave of cases meaning they believe that
omicron is essentially done or ending in
south africa and it counts very few
added deaths now if you're saying but
david a lot of things are different here
we're going to get to that we're going
to get to that new york times the south
african government said thursday data
suggests the country has passed its
omicron peak without a major spike in
deaths offering cautious hope to other
countries grappling with the variant
some scientists were quick to forecast
the pattern elsewhere so let's look at
the numbers that we had um
now as you can see if you're watching
you you can see
this massive case spike i mean going
from
about 300 cases a day
to 23 000 cases a day okay that's that's
almost uh uh you know a 200x increase at
150 or something like that increase in
cases
but
their cases are now down
something like what's that 16 over 24
down about 66
but deaths had a very modest spike we
don't not care about these deaths
they're still tragic
but when you see that cases went up what
150 to 200 times
and deaths went up from about 30 a day
to like 60 a day you say that that's
pretty notable that's pretty notable now
why might it be different
in the united states or in other
countries there's a bunch of different
reasons first of all
during earlier waves
south africa had very low levels of
vaccination meaning that earlier waves
sort of burned through the population
large parts of the population
the beta variant which was not huge
outside of south africa
went through there that may provide more
um
sort of a population protection to s
these are questions it may remember that
delta different lineage than omicron not
believed to provide not believed to
provide significant protection against
omicron omicron is based on an earlier
lineage it split earlier so to speak
it's theorized that the beta variant
having burned through south africa
might make omicron particularly less
severe in south africa and we might not
have that we don't have that and it may
be notable in the united states that's
number one so we have to wait and see
number two
the south african population is much
younger than the united states five
percent of south africa's population is
65 plus
16 of the u.s population is 65 plus
that's very different so
if we have to guess right now
there's these two competing stories
it'll be insanely bad in the united
states or it'll be just like south
africa
the most likely scenario based on what
we have now because lower rate of
hospitalization is being observed in a
lot of different places is that it will
be worse in the us than in south africa
but it won't be nearly as bad on a on
the case rate basis
as earlier waves were
the other thing that's sort of important
to remember
is in the uk
even the rising hospitalization numbers
a ton of the people hospitalized with
kovid
are not hospitalized because of covid
when you test everyone who is in the
hospital and you have something so
contagious that could be 40 asymptomatic
you're going to find tons of people who
have it and are in the hospital for
something else they still count
so my view here is still cautious
optimism
and we're going to continue looking at
the numbers
we have a kind of nice way to start 2022
in a very particular sense
amongst a lot of bad news and that's
that radical right
lunatic republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene has been
permanently banned from twitter for
continuing to spread covet
disinformation now there are people
acting like we'll get to the people
saying this is fascism it's very funny
we'll get to that
people acting like this was on a whim
with no forethought or basis
this was her fifth strike
uh there's an article in the new york
times twitter permanently suspends
marjorie taylor green's account
social media service says she violated
its covet misinformation policy
um twitter suspended her account after
she tweeted on saturday falsely about
quote extremely high amounts of coveted
vaccine deaths she included a misleading
chart that pulled information from a
government data database of unverified
raw data
called vares
a decade old system that relies on
self-reported cases from patients and
healthcare providers twitter said ms
green had a fifth strike which meant her
account will not be restored
the company had issued her a fourth
strike in august when she falsely posted
vaccines were failing she had a third
strike a month before that when she
treated covid was not dangerous
and vaccines should not be mandated
her official congressional account rep
mtg
remains active because tweets from that
account didn't violate the services rule
so just to go through it element by
element
i'm showing people the rep mtg account
that one has about 400 000 followers she
has not posted there since december 24th
where she posted a christmas message of
some kind um
i'll just play a few seconds of it and i
will warn you listening to her speak is
extremely triggering in a lot of
different ways on behalf of myself my
family and staff i want to wish all
americans and especially those in the
14th district okay i i already i mean
okay we're done with that
um there are some people reacting to
this in ways
that uh
don't don't really make a lot of sense
to me
um a lot of people are calling this so
so there's a but
i don't even know where to start
first there's people criticizing and
saying that we need regulation
twitter shouldn't be allowed to do this
um
why can't businesses have terms of
service that they enforce
and and that i mean that's just what it
is
there's a lot of confusion from people
who generally say businesses should be
allowed to do whatever they want as long
as it's not illegal and very few things
should be illegal who are saying
businesses shouldn't be allowed to
require vaccines well hold on can they
require that you wear a shirt yeah
can they require that you wear shoes
yeah
if you don't like it can you choose just
not to go there yeah
but they can't do vaccines okay doesn't
make sense that's one hypocrisy but then
the other one is
they are saying there should be
something that the government does
to prevent these businesses from
deciding for themselves what they want
to do as long as it's not illegal
now there's another aspect of this which
is people saying this is authoritarian
fascism
former guest brian class he's been on a
couple times and he was on a few months
ago he had a really great perspective on
this which you can find on twitter and
he wrote whenever twitter suspends
someone for spreading deadly lies
someone will call it authoritarianism or
fascism it's the opposite it's a free
market company making decisions without
government interference or directives
fascism is the inverse fascism is
extreme state control and brian goes on
to say there are complicated free speech
issues around social media which we all
i mean anybody who's thoughtful agrees
with that
but i can assure you says brian that
twitter couldn't make its own choices to
ban government officials somewhere like
north korea they would instantly be shut
down we don't have fascism here because
twitter can do this and at least for now
the government isn't saying you gotta
allow marjorie taylor green to lie about
vaccines or trump to do whatever
so let's be consistent
is it illegal
to do what twitter is doing it is not
well then by their definition if it's
not illegal it's okay and people can
choose to boycott uh there's many of you
might remember or know or you know
whatever that the david pakman show
started in the city i grew up in
northampton massachusetts
and i still have a lot of friends in
northampton and recently there was a
hearing held by the northampton board of
health about businesses requiring
vaccines more and more businesses you
know i hear from friends this business
that business is requiring vaccines i
have friends who own businesses in
northampton they say we're going to
require vaccines of customers and they
had this this hearing via zoom and you
know people could comment on facebook
and and elsewhere
and you have all these people
making conflicting and different
arguments it's like you about this is
the worst decision ever this is this is
authoritarianism this is nazi this is
fascism this is all these different
things
break it down element by element is it
illegal for a business to
require proof of vaccines i don't even
care about does it do anything i've said
at this point this thing is so
contagious
that the vaccines primarily are
protecting people from serious illness
hospitalization and death it's still it
the cat is out of the bag this thing is
clearly going to burn its way through
whether there's a vaccine requirement at
a local restaurant or not but is it
illegal to require vaccines no okay
so now we're just in the realm of
opinion
you don't like
businesses that require vaccination then
don't go to them it's really that simple
marjorie taylor green knew what the
rules were at this point she chose to
break them it's her fault she should be
banned that's it officials don't get a
special allowance to spread
disinformation about a public health
crisis because they're elected officials
she was elected by georgia trumpists to
represent them it doesn't mean that you
get a national platform or global
platform to tell lies that violate the
policy of twitter
is twitter discriminating against people
on the basis of race when they do these
things no are they discriminating on the
basis of national origin no
if you don't like it you don't have to
use twitter that it that that's
fundamentally what it is and this really
does matter and what i mean by that is
when trump was banned from twitter
uh mango
mussolini the tangerine terror you guys
remember the guy
the amount in general
of hate speech
went down the amount of people weren't
then re-amplifying the stuff trump was
putting out there so
this works and it's legal if you don't
like it that's a different story and if
you want to propose regulation of
twitter of some kind
i'm glad to discuss it
but then we have to be able to say we
should be regulating all regulating all
sorts of different businesses that
right-wingers always say let them do
whatever they want as long as it's not
illegal as of right now i want to hear
from you guys um we'll post uh more
about this on our instagram you can find
us there at david pakman show
so we're continuing our
discovery for lack of a better term of
who did what who knew what who tried
what in the lead-up to the november of
2020 election in the period between the
november election and the january sixth
riots and then after the january six
riots to try to cover up
what was done tried said and attempted
during that previous period of time and
a lot of the stuff we're learning we're
learning
thanks to the work of this house select
committee investigating the january six
riots in the next segment
uh we're going to have some uh
incredible revelations from republic
republican congresswoman liz cheney but
before we get to that
we are now getting a list of documents
from the house committee
we don't yet or won't have all of the
content of each of these documents
but what we know so far is i mean
chilling and disturbing is probably an
understatement listen to this
chilling trump letter
calling for seizure of election material
revealed in log to january 6 probers the
letter was created a day before trump
discussed naming conspiracy theorist
sidney powell special counsel to probe
baseless election fraud claims
the document in question and you can
find this is there's a pdf and i'm
putting it up on the screen you can find
this this is publicly available
mixed in with a whole bunch of other
documents which may or may not be
interesting to you
there is an item called draft potus
letter meaning a draft letter from trump
and it says it is described as draft
letter from potus to seize evidence in
the interest of national security for
the 2020 elections
now
there are
a few interpretations of what this
could be and they're all absolutely
terrifying let's go back to this
huffington post article which outlines a
bunch of it the log along with a trove
of documents was provided last week they
were handed over by trump ally bernie
carrick former nypd commissioner and
confidant of rudy giuliani carrick was a
key advisor to trump's legal team trying
to cook up a narrative of fraud in the
presidential election that joe biden won
besides the documents carrick turned
over he also offered a log of documents
he refused to provide including the
trump letter among the documents
withheld is one described as draft
letter from potus to seize evidence in
the interest of national security in the
2020 election though trump ultimately
didn't take action to seize election
materials such a letter could be a key
piece of information in the
investigation into trump's strategy to
undermine a legitimate election
authorities have found no evidence of
fraud the letter was created december
18th that's the day before he met with
general flynn and others to try to
figure out what to do trump also
discussed naming far-right attorney
conspiracy theorist sydney powell a
special counsel he ultimately didn't do
that flynn had already suggested trump
could invoke martial law to seize
control of the election remember
this is the guy
who
wanted to review voter registrations
nationally right that's one idea trump
floated i believe it was in advance of
the midterms um this is not someone who
considers
sacred
uh information related to people's uh
actual voting and what it means sees
information is not even exactly clear
but it's extraordinarily authoritarian
you know we talked earlier all of these
right wingers say
when twitter banned marjorie taylor
green for cova disinformation when
twitter banned dr robert malone for
covet disinformation that's
authoritarian fascism no it's not it's a
private business enforcing terms of
service in a completely legal way on the
other hand
when a sitting president drafts a letter
saying let's seize election materials
which could be
mail-in ballots
it could be
voting machines it could be all sorts of
different things let's seize it and try
to use it to steal the election which
was of course the goal
that in and of itself deserves an
investigation that is the authoritarian
nightmare that these right-wingers say
twitter is actually doing when we now
understand the context of all of this
which was trying to do an insurrectious
coup
what exactly
did trump and his legal team plan on
doing with the voting data
even the guy trump put in charge
remember that whole committee that but
you might have forgotten about it
because it found nothing but i think it
was called the voter integrity
commission or committee or something he
put that guy uh kris kobach the kansas
secretary of state in charge of it um it
found nothing
even he wasn't willing to seize the
voter information back during that
period or wasn't willing
maybe just realized it wouldn't work
right um and as i was reading all of
this over the weekend i don't know how
many of you saw the recent film don't
look up with leonardo dicaprio and
jennifer lawrence and a bunch of other
actors
it feels much more like a documentary
than satire the more we read about what
this administration was doing uh towards
uh towards the very end the honestly the
the most
so there may be a spoiler here there may
be a spoiler there maybe a spoiler about
the the film don't look up
the most unrealistic part of don't look
up
was that some people actually changed
their minds once they saw the comet with
their own eyes
trumpists would have claimed even
looking at the comment you can't believe
that you can only believe what trump
says it must be a soros-founded
projection that looks like a comment
meant to scare us into accepting
government control or whatever i mean
that's how weaponized this
disinformation has become and as we
learn about all of the things they
almost tried
uh it makes it even more urgent that we
put in safeguards so that they can't
even get this going in uh 2024 and we've
talked about that earlier we're going to
talk about it again
uh
206 marines have been discharged for
refusing the covet vaccine
now you might say wait but david don't
they get
the hep a vaccine and the hep b vaccine
and the flu vaccine and the mmr vaccine
and the meningococcal vaccine and the
poliovirus vaccine and the tetanus
diphtheria vaccine and the varicella
vaccine and depending on where they're
deployed the anthrax vaccine and the
hemophilus influenza type b vaccine and
the japanese encephalitis vaccine and
the pneumococcal vaccine and the rabies
smallpox typhoid yellow okay
all right
yes they do
but this is different this is about
their rights all right so the bottom
line is every time we hear they're gonna
lose a third of the service
nypd one-third are saying
34 new york police department officers
actually discharged actually discharged
and so when i read
more than 200 marines removed for
defying covet mandate
i think this seems like a good thing
what i mean by that is
when we found out at the end of the day
34
nypd officers were removed for not
getting the vaccine
i don't know that those are the good
apples that we actually want in nypd
anyway
uh and much the same way
if these are the 206 that are being
removed there's something like 18 000
marines or something no i'm sorry 180
000 marines this represents
0.11 percent of them i think this is
fine these don't sound like team player
marines report from axios us marine
corps said it removed 206 service
members for refusing the vaccine updated
numbers come as dod has ramped up
repercussions for those defying the
vaccine order the branch said it had
already discharged 103.
the big picture approximately 94 percent
of active members are fully vaccinated
as of last week roughly 98 of all active
duty forces including reserves have
received the vaccine remember that
defense secretary lloyd austin in august
said all troops must get the vaccine
encourage service leaders to set up
their own timelines to date
approximately 3 247 requests for
religious accommodation over the vaccine
have been made
zero have been approved according to a
marine corps communication officer one
note about that
um
this doesn't mean everyone else is
vaccinated
some of those requests
although they haven't been approved for
an exemption they may still be in
process so that's where you get that's
why we're still short of a hundred
percent there are people who have made a
request for an exemption it has not yet
been adjudicated or even if it has it
has not yet led to a discharge and so
that's all going to have to sort of be
sorted out service members can request
to opt out of mandatory
um
health elements
on the base of vaccination on the basis
of a health situation
an administrative reason i i don't know
exactly what would count as that or a
religious exemption
um those can be temporarily granted or
permanently granted so far from what
we're seeing none of them have been
granted for marines uh i read a comment
and i don't i don't know i mean this is
it's just a comment from one member of
the us navy
that there are service members
who are looking for a way out
and that refusing a vaccine is a way to
get an honorable discharge
maybe benefits maybe benefits although
we're we're hearing conflicting things
about benefits um and that this is a way
for some people who are looking to leave
anyway to do it while saving face that's
one opinion from one member of the u.s
navy who wrote to me
take it for what it is which is which is
simply an anecdote but the the big
takeaway continues to be
the legality of these requirements is
not in question the morality can be
argued
the effectiveness is also not in
question these work and you know united
airlines was a big one where much hubbub
was made
and like everybody got vaccinated other
than i think it was 200 people or
something like that so these
requirements do work
there's a fair debate to be had about in
the context of omicron where there is
only some protection some protection
from two doses against getting a
symptomatic infection
what is really the goal here well the
primary goal seems to be to keep the
burden on hospitals down by preventing
people from ending up hospitalized but
these next four weeks are going to be
wild the numbers are insane that we are
seeing
and maybe by tomorrow maybe by wednesday
we'll have kind of like the full catch
caught up numbers from the holiday
and then we'll see how things are
looking at that point
all right i teased this earlier let's uh
let's get right to it there is now um a
statement that has been made by
republican congresswoman liz chaney
who's on the house select convi
committee investigating the january six
riots
she says they have first-hand testimony
that ivanka trump among others but
ivanka trump the president the former
president's own daughter
asked donald trump please do something
to stop these riots on january 6th and
of course he did not and this continues
to kind of
flesh out the picture that we are
building
about
exactly who did what and when on that
day what were the goals what were the
intentions what were the priorities of
different people and this is just
unbelievable liz cheney we have
firsthand testimony ivanka asked trump
to stop the january 6th capital riot
the house select committee investigating
the riots has received firsthand
testimony that trump's daughter ivanka
twice asked him to intervene trump was
watching the riot unfold on tv while
sitting in the dining room next to the
oval office at the time
let's go right into the clips this is
liz cheney appearing yesterday with
george stephanopoulos on abc
it is uh
it's everything we imagined guys
is his failure to make that statement
criminal negligence
you know uh i think that that there are
a number of as the chairman said uh
potential criminal statutes uh at issue
here uh but i think that that there's
absolutely no question that it was a
dereliction of duty uh and and i think
one of the things the committee needs to
look at as we're looking at a
legislative purpose is whether we need
enhanced penalties for that kind of
dereliction of duty now i want to be
real there's a reason she's saying this
and this goes back to what we talked
about uh last week
officially a congressional committee's
main purpose can't be to figure out if
someone committed a crime
and trump has tried to stop the
investigation by saying they're
primarily just looking to see if i
committed a crime
liz cheney is saying
exactly what she has to say now whether
it's true or maybe they are primarily
looking at whether trump committed a
crime but at least what has to be said
is
our interest is as lawmakers are there
laws we need to pass to prevent this
from happening again
if we happen to come across crimes that
were committed in so figuring that out
then we can refer those crimes there's a
if you saw that segment last week you
understand the legal relevance of that
but let's continue
uh but but i think it's also important
for the american people to understand
how dangerous donald trump was
we know as he was sitting there in the
dining room next to the oval office
members of his staff were pleading with
him to go on television to tell people
to stop we know leader mccarthy
was pleading with him to do that we know
members of his family we know his
daughter we have first-hand testimony
that his daughter ivanka
went in at least twice
to ask him to please stop this violence
any man who would not do so any man who
would provoke a violent assault on the
capitol to stop the counting of
electoral votes any man who would watch
television as police officers were being
beaten
as as his supporters were invading the
capital of the united states is clearly
unfit for future office
clearly can never be anywhere near the
oval office
ever again so this was a very
interesting and wide-ranging interview
let's go to another segment here where
the topic is again at any point trump
could have put a stop to this any point
and he did not we're joined now by the
vice chair of the committee
congresswoman liz cheney councilman
cheney thank you for joining us again
this morning happy new year
to you
you know you were alarmed by this from
the very start from the moment so the
first moments on january 6 when this
started to unfold you've cut a lonely
path in your party have you been
surprised by anything you found over the
last year
well i've certainly been surprised by
many things i think that in the piece
that you played by john carl just a few
moments ago
he touched on the fact
that that we know now we are learning
much more about what former president
trump was doing while the violent
assault was underway the committee has
first-hand testimony now that he was
sitting in the dining room next to the
oval office watching the attack on
television as as the assault on the
capitol occurred
we know
as you you know well
that the briefing room at the white
house is just a mere few steps from the
oval office the president could have at
any moment walked those very few steps
into the briefing room gone on live
television and told his supporters who
were assaulting the capitol to stop he
could have told them to stand down he
could have told him to go home
and he failed to do so uh it's hard to
imagine a more significant and more
serious dereliction of duty it's funny
to say he failed because it does i mean
he didn't he chose not to do it failed
almost suggests he wasn't able but he
chose not to and uh two-thirds of the
country and a lot of the world asked the
exact same questions liz cheney is
asking here which is why why not do it
and um one last segment here and again
this is this is liz cheney
she's she's
all power to her she's saying we have to
be loyal here to the country not to
trump and this isn't good for the
republican party liz cheney is a
right-wing republican
with whom i disagree on just about
everything she voted with trump
something like 93 percent of the time
but on this particular issue she is
correct you're about as stalwart
republican as i've ever met you come
from a long line of republicans as well
of course your father served
in the white house your mother served in
in administrations as well how do you
explain given your belief your views in
your background
why a majority of republicans today
would re-elect donald trump
look i i think that
we're in a situation as a nation where i
certainly have very strong disagreements
with policies of the biden
administration i think that that
policies that vice president president
biden has adopted
are the wrong ones for this country i
think we need conservative principled
leadership but the republican party has
to make a choice we can either be loyal
to our constitution or loyal to donald
trump but we cannot be both and the
nation needs a republican party that is
based on substance and values and
principles uh and and we've got to get
back to that if we want to get this
nation back on track but fundamentally
at the end of the day we we can't be a
party that's based on lies we've got to
be based on a foundation of truth
and fidelity to the rule of law so
listen she she's saying all the right
things and i applaud her for it i do
this is still not someone who's going to
be one of our political allies but would
we be better off if more republicans
saw trumpism and their party and country
really as three different things and
that you can be on the side of one or
two of those without having to stand by
donald trump of course we would be
better off of course we would be better
off so there is liz cheney ivanka ivanka
firsthand testimony that ivanka multiple
times tried to get trump to do something
uh and trump didn't until hours later
said in a video it's time to go home we
love you
we know why you're here it was stolen
but it's time to go home a completely
pathetic pathetic almost non-reaction to
the horrors of january 6. then trump
will be doing a press conference on
thursday january 6th the anniversary of
the riots making some kind of statement
we don't know what that will be but we
can be almost certain it's going to be
completely whacked out
the ron desantis story just keeps
getting more and more insane let me re
reset this for you
the last time up until recently that ron
desantis the uh republican very trumpy
and florida governor ron desantis was
seen in public was december 17th
on december 17th he showed up at bay
galicious delhi and bakery in oak in
ocala
and he took a picture this is from the
begalicious delian bakery page on
facebook
dated december 17th they posted even the
governor loves bagalicious
so this was the last time he was seen in
public and nearly two weeks went by
nearly two weeks went by
and then
all of a sudden
the desantis people came out and said oh
he was with his wife at her cancer
treatment ron desantis's wife
is being treated for breast cancer and
our thoughts of course are with her and
we hope that the treatment goes well
but that is the explanation for why he
was missing for two weeks didn't really
make sense because apparently that was
only on december 29th that he was with
her
it then got even weirder
because on december 30th the ron
desantis official twitter account posted
the very same picture
of desantis at the bagalicious as if it
was that day
had some great bagels from bagelicious
in ocala stop by if you're in the area
so
understand that
it's very weird
this is the last public picture of
desantis anywhere we know the picture is
from december 17th because bagalicious
posted it on december 17th and then on
the 30th after
tons of people saying where is this guy
covet is exploding it's complete in
total chaos he's mia he says no look
here i'm out in public but they post a
picture that is 13 almost 14 days old
okay so that's all really really weird
but then this is just the worst part of
it and this is this is just sad i don't
know how else to say it this is just sad
um
there is now video
of ron desantis
at a huge concert on new year's eve
with his wife who has cancer
unmasked
um
everybody should assess risk for
themselves of course you know it's
your wife has cancer
we have an insanely contagious variant
florida is setting case records every
single day
and you go to a massive event without
masks i mean what
what are you doing that this is
dangerous to her take a look at this and
so in florida
you can mark it down we will not let
anyone shut you down
[Music]
[Applause]
and we are going to make sure that our
rights are respected and that's what
we've done and that's what we'll
continue to do so i hope you all have a
very very good
2022
i think there's going to be a lot of
good things on the horizon and
we're looking forward to being able to
do a lot for the state looking forward
for my wife to beat breast cancer which
is going to happen
[Applause]
and so thank you and
keep
fighting all right so you get it i mean
listen we all hope that she beats breast
cancer
bringing her in the middle of peak covet
unmasked to a huge event where we have a
prevalence where by by some estimates
12 to 18 of the country currently has
coveted um
seems incredibly unwise but just a very
strange story missing for almost two
weeks says well i'm missing because i
was with my wife at cancer treatment
except when you look that was only on
the 29th posts a picture from two weeks
earlier saying hey here i am in public
and then you show up unmasked at this
everything about this guy disgusts me
and that certainly doesn't change with
this latest episode oh we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
david p here's a really instructive
question from a viewer take a look at
this
yeah david you describe yourself as a
left winger right
but seems like you're a pretty big
supporter of capitalism
how do you reconcile that
yeah
well listen that this this goes to some
significant confusion
um most left-wingers
are not socialists this is just it's an
empirical reality
uh
most
many left-wingers like me
support socialization of some elements
of society in the economy i want to take
health care outside of the capitalist
system i want to take education outside
of that there are arguments for
with some aspects of housing but not all
taking it outside of just supply and
demand and markets but most left-wingers
are not actually socialists even in
countries like my birth country of
argentina with big socialist traditions
most of the left-wingers are not
actually socialists so there's no
conflict i'm a social democrat
in the style
of some blend of northern european
countries i support a much much more
regulated and controlled version of
capitalism whose main priority is let's
use the fruits of that regulated
capitalism to set a much higher floor
for everybody for the betterment of all
let's also set some kind of ceiling
above which we really are collecting a
lot of taxes for the betterment of
society it's called social democracy but
i don't need
uh
i'm fine with
markets dictating resource allocation
for
consumer electronics
vehicles products of different kinds i'm
okay with that i think it's okay i think
if you build something
um
and it's a company and it's yours and
you built it i don't think that should
be taken away from you however we
recognize that you built it based on
utility infrastructure established by
the government and through taxation
protection for intellectual property
established by the government presumably
with employees many of whom went to
public schools which is paid for by
through tax right when we recognize well
yeah you you organized the structure and
you built it and so you do deserve many
of the fruits of that labor it was also
built on the backs of all sorts of
government infrastructure and tax
dollars etc etc so that's why we have to
cycle back a portion of it into the
betterment of society that's
fundamentally social democracy
it is a left-wing perspective i would
argue
it's the most successful
most successful version
of progressive ideology globally over
the last 150 years okay so that's my
perspective we've got a great bonus show
for you today
uh absolutely insane travel chaos and
it's not just omicron causing it we will
talk about hillary clinton's
interesting 2024 prediction we'll talk
about how on earth do schools reopen
with omicron spreading so wildly
and much more all of those stories on
today's bonus show sign up at
joinpakman.com
and you can use the coupon code wow 22.
and when you type it in you have to you
have to say
wow 22.
it saves you big you get access to the
bonus show you join the ranks of
membership for what will be a really
important election year i'll see you
then
you